another week and a whole mess of new
games are headed your way fortunately
for you and me and less fortunately for
our wallets there's a pretty good week
of games hitting shelves here's what's
coming up over the next few days if
November is just a too damn far away for
you to get your post apocalypse picks on
you could pick up the fallout anthology
which is set to land on sep tember 29
for PC the anthology includes a fallout
Fallout 2 full out tactics fallout 3
game of the year edition and fallout new
vegas ultimate edition in one package
but wait i hear you ask i already bought
the fallout pack when it was on sale on
steam why would i want to buy all these
games again well dear viewer that's
because this collection comes inside of
a fat man mini nuke which makes egg bomb
sound effect and it has a spot for your
fallout 4 copy come November 10 did that
steam bundle come inside of an awesome
children's toy no it did not so there
you go in the realm of game releases
that make me make weird sounds mine
magic hero 7 is landing this week and I
am just so excited whether you've kept
up with the series or stopped playing at
heroes 3 like most people the new
installment is hoping to grab your
attention on sep tember 29 as the first
major release in the series in four
years the game takes place 200 years
after the events of heroes six shades of
darkness it features six factions which
include Haven Academy stronghold Sylvan
necropolis and dungeon as well as
turn-based gameplay and a brand new
campaign to get stuck into if waiting to
take your turn is not really your thing
you can hit the courts in real-time with
NBA 2k16 on September
9 although it is the 17th damn
installment the very pretty game
features over 1500 different tattoo
designs for some reason better player
customization as well as new animations
you can also crack into the returning my
career mode where you follow a gifted
youngster from high school to the
high-stakes world of the NBA just try
not to get distracted by all the sex
drugs and rock and roll along the way
NBA Live 16 is also landing on the same
day for ps4 and Xbox one it has improved
a dribbling shooting passing and other
basketball words as well as its rising
star game mode and the live motion
system which improves physics-based
player movement if you like your sports
games with a little more speed and peril
you can crack into Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater 5 on the twenty-ninth when it
arrives on ps4 and Xbox one the ps3 and
xbox 360 editions are jus out in
November it's a fairly momentous
occasion since the last major
installment in the series came out in
2007 ketchum out tricks on both online
and offline throughout levels that
transition from single to multiplayer
seamlessly you can embody a number of
pro skaters or customize your own and
you'll be able to create parks with the
Creator Park feature if you so choose
that's got to be skate parks and not
like dog parks but the game hasn't come
out yet so I can't confirm if you found
persona 4 golden to be grind heavy but
not in the right ways you can get your
groove on properly in persona for
dancing all night when it comes out for
the PlayStation Vita atlases upcoming
rhythm game takes place a month after
the epilogue of persona 4 golden it
features a very complicated series of
events which include a cursed internet
video involuntary transportation
kidnapping and age a pop idol group
called kahneman kitchen which animated
characters dance better than we ever
will on sep tember 29 let me know down
in that comity text box what game is
getting your attention this week and why
as always release dates are based on
retailer listings and a sub
to change have yourselves a lovely week
just watch me everyone I'm gonna reach
out and touch your heart